what does the budget mean for ordinary
households well during the course of
today no sooner the chances of finished
speaking than we started to run some
numbers and we've been looking at three
households in particular we've been
looking at Linda a retired nurse we've
been looking at Mike a comfortably off
I.T consultant and we've been looking at
Leanne a fitness instructor and also a
mother of a child so we've tried to
understand for each of these households
what today's announcements mean let's
start with Linda Linda is on pension and
disability support although her husband
still works as a result she's seen as
well as that benefit from the freeze in
the energy price guarantee that's the 3
000 pounds that's staying at 2500 that's
good news she's also seen an
inflationary increase in her personal
Independence payments that's the
disability allowance and the benefit of
the fuel Duty freeze that was announced
today
however some of that is offset by this
negative sum this this balance which is
a result of income taxes being frozen
that's called fiscal drag and it's a
stealth tax we'll talk about that more
in a minute but taken as a whole Linda
is a winner from today's budget we think
her households up about 350 pounds over
the next 12 months let's understand that
fiscal drag idea in a bit more detail
now a household like Linda's a
comfortably earning but not earning a
lot only sees a modest effect because of
those tax thresholds Frozen but
households on higher incomes 50 000 and
up they are seeing a very significant
effect as a result of their earnings
Rising but income tax thresholds staying
the same as a result every year they're
paying more tax essentially they're
getting dragged into those higher rate
tax bans and those numbers can really
add up let's take Mike as an example of
this so Mike's household as a result of
this budget also benefits a larger house
from that energy price cap and it
benefits from the freezing fuel duties
but look what happens to Mike's
household situation over the next 12
months an enormous cost associated with
those rise with those frozen income
thresholds as his salary increases and
so the consequence of putting those
pieces together is on a overall basis we
analyze Mike a slightly worse off as a
result of this budget
finally let's look at Leanne a fitness
instructor she lives with her husband
also self-employed and their daughter a
four-year-old too young unfortunately to
benefit from all the child care
giveaways that the chancellor announced
earlier on energy price guarantee good
news child benefit increase very good
news for this household fuel duty-free
is excellent given how much this
household needs to drive but also losers
as a result of that fiscal drag effect
that stealth tax creeping in so overall
a household which is a little better off
as a result of the budget so there we
have it Leanne Mike Linda three very
different households three very
different pictures some winners and some
losers from today's announcement